بين هذه الانقاب طمرت حقيقه اسوا زلزال
مدمر ضرب تركيا وبين ذات الانقاض يبحث
منفذ القانون عن العداله لضحايا الزلزال
بناء نحن محامون نعمل كمتطوعين من اجل
اعطاء الاولويه لتصوير المباني وكذلك
تحديد الادله التي ستقدم لاحقا كاساس
للادله في اجراءات المحكمه نقابات
المحامين في محافظات تركيه مختلفه ارسلت
حوالي 81 فردا لجمع البيانات الهامه وذلك
منذ وقوع الزلزال الذي اودى بحياه اكثر من
47 الف شخص في تركيا وخلف اضرارا تقدر
باكثر من مئه مليار دولار حسب الامم
المتحده
نحاول تحديد الدليل من خلال التجول حيا
تلو الاخر شارعا شارعا ولاننا لن نتمكن من
الوصول الى الكثير من الادله بعد ازاله
الحطام تلك الادله التي يجوب المحامون عده
شوارع سيرا الاقدام ودون مقابل مادي
ياملون ان تسمح بعد جمعها في قاعده بيانات
وطنيه بمحاكمه المسؤولين عن الخسائر
الفادحه يوما ما تقوم كما تشركوك لدينا
زملائه متطوعون في عشر مناطق مختلفه ولا
يتلقى زملائنا اي مدفوعات مقابل هذا على
العكس من ذلك ترك الجميع اعمالهم واتوا
الى هذه المنطقه بهدف تقديم الحقيقه كما
هي السلطات التركيه اعتقلت عشرات المشتبه
بهم وبدات اجراءات القانونيه ضد الف شخص
متورطين في تشييد هذه المباني بمن فيهم
عدد من من حاولوا الفرار من البلاد لكن
احقاق العدل يتطلب سرعه في التحرك تواكب
سرعه ازاله الحطام
روان حمزه العربيه